[Music]
uh hello plastic pills listeners this is
victor
again god damn it
maybe we should just keep that in
hello plastic pills listeners i'm here
with matt uh eric and uh guest special
guest and friend of the show ben burgess
we're here to plug yet another of matt's
edited volumes but this time all of us
here have actually written an essay for
it the name matt remind me it's
liberalism and socialism or verses it's
not verses is it
uh no that would have been fun though uh
liberalism and socialism mortal enemies
or embittered kin
uh for the palgrave studies and
classical liberalism line yeah for sure
and we'll obviously have a link in the
description for those of you who want to
spend like 100 in an academic book or
just like wait and get it from your
library probably shouldn't shouldn't buy
from the from the press but in any case
so pills is not here because he doesn't
care about liberalism or socialism and
doesn't want to hear us talk about it
um
but today i guess we just want to
explore and compare
uh liberalism and socialism as we've
done
many times in the past but this time
we've all written essays on it so i
don't know matt what do you think in
term when you think about uh
distinguishing liberalism and socialism
a lot of our listeners especially the
more marxist-oriented ones definitely
want to deny that there's
you know any relationship between them
um i'm hearing a dog in the background
of liberalism and socialism
i think the dog is saying that they are
definitely embittered uh very embittered
so matt i don't know what would you say
in terms of like the compatibility is it
compatible are them are the rr marxist
listeners right that you know being a
lib is the is a is a mortal sin there
are two catalysts really one was the uh
rise of bernie sanders and other figures
like aoc uh back in the day jeremy
corbyn uh to kind of the forefront of
political movements in their respective
countries what was interesting about
this for me is being a millennial who
kind of grew up at the end of history
when socialism is supposed to be a dead
word uh you had all these people who
were kind of resuscitating it and i
thought that was very politically
intriguing and also to my own taste
since i liked a lot of the policies that
were advancing um
the second thing uh that interested me
about this uh was of course the fact
that trumpism and the emergence of a lot
of these hard or far-right movements
however you want to characterize them
were
broadly speaking opposed to both
liberalism and leftism uh which included
socialism while at the same time they
tended to borrow characteristics
features arguments from both of these
traditions uh so what i was hoping to do
in this book was talk a little bit about
what the distinctions that overlaps are
between liberalism and socialism
and whether they can be reconciled in
any way shape or form i think they can
but we can get into that
because i wanted to kind of demarcate
what each of these traditions stands for
uh with a little bit more clarity right
i was wondering
ben i was wondering uh whether you think
what you think about this idea that
maybe like isms because i've often
thought you know when we try to when we
try to like define our ideologies
according to this label i think there
can be
a temptation or or it almost leads to
some sort of like i think um reasoning
flaw where like unt i'll give you this
example so when we when there was this
whole debate about whether trump was a
fascist or not i know you've been
engaged in that question before we i
think you've probably talked about it on
your show before and maybe written about
it as well actually
um
and i think that like
sometimes
when we try to label something with an
ism
we end up
distorting our ability to be specific
about why that thing is good or bad so
it's like you know people want to label
trump a fascist because it's just some
sort of synonym for him being bad
whereas maybe we could argue what would
be more useful is to just be like
specific about
what trump does and like why that's bad
the reasons for why that's bad and i
wonder whether there would be like some
sort of analogous problem where like
when we try to define ourselves as
socialist or liberal
it's like we are almost putting some
barrier between us just talking
specifically
about like what we want that would be
good like what would be the good
outcomes that we would want yeah
uh i i think that i think that labels
can be really useful as a shorthand
um
i mean i think the trump is a fascist
thing is really interesting example
because
i would argue that although
look i mean i don't really like i'm not
i don't i'm not gonna be the guy who
like if somebody
you know is using the word in clearly an
expressive sense
right you know as as as just kind of a
way of expressing like really strong
visceral distaste you know that like i'm
not gonna be the guy who's like stand
down sidelines well actually right it's
like okay in that context i know what
you mean it's fine right but
i i think one reason i have been
critical of the of the you know trump
fascism analogies is that i think
they're often
misleading about why trump was bad
because he was very bad uh but
uh but i think that
not really in the way that classical
fascists uh were were bad uh that
you know most of what he did i mean
certainly his immigration policies you
know were
even crueler and and more vindictive you
know that other conservatives
immigration policies have been
but outside of that context almost
everything that he did really was what
mitt romney would have done and and and
like that's bad republicans are bad i'm
against them you know but uh but i don't
know how helpful it is called fascist
especially because
uh
you know i i know you you could tell you
know you could tell our schnauzer you
know really disagrees with this analysis
but i'm just gonna i'm just gonna keep
going uh
that
i think especially because if you think
about kovan which is really one of the
worst things trump did was coven
response
but the problem with trump's covert
response wasn't that it was too fascist
uh it was almost the opposite of that
you know that that uh that it was way
too lazy fair you know that uh that like
i i could have used a little more
authoritarianism in the covent response
as opposed to what we had which was
basically mass murder by neglect
um
so i think these can be useful can i
just interject there and say that i've
often conceived of like a different
universe where trump goes the opposite
direction and probably wins the election
uh but he just comes up there he's like
we're gonna have a war the hardest war
against kovid your government is gonna
be here for you we're gonna have the the
tightest restrictions in the world
tighter than anything tighter than any
[ __ ] i've ever been in and believe me
i've been in a lot right a lot like that
kind of speech and like just the whole
trajectory of what goes on yeah at all
yeah absolutely i could totally imagine
that world and yeah whole trajectory is
different all the maga people love it
which they would and um
and all of the russian obsessed
resistance types become antimasters
which is 100 what would have happened uh
in that universe i i don't know if the
slightest doubt about that but uh
but yeah i i think that's right in fact
actually if you look at hungry i mean
victor orban kind of did go that route a
little bit you know he he said
like oh this is an emergency no
elections you know that's kind of gotta
let me do whatever i want it's an
emergency it's like okay that's how a
fascist would handle govind
is that way
but i think so i think that that example
maybe could show that these are these
can be
look i mean you can't do politics
without shorthands
uh because like you know if you're
writing a philosophical essay you could
spend five paragraphs disambiguating
exactly what you mean but like you just
can't do that you know for any kind of
mass political communication
and even in a philosophical essay like
you know
like you can't like you're gonna have an
infinite regress problem if you don't
start with like some like okay you kind
of know what i mean by this and you know
we could do a little disambiguating but
like you know you sort of have to start
somewhere
so i i do think it's probably
unavoidable but i i also like your
impulse there because uh you know you
were talking earlier about
you know uh sort of orthodox marxist
listeners not liking the the suggestion
of uh
that there's that you know liberalism
and socialism could be anything other uh
than mortal enemies
you know the danger of the shorthands
is that
they end up um
you know people end up thinking about
you know things like in this weird
short-circuited way like okay i agree
with marks what does mark say i agree
with that right rather than okay what is
the specific thing that mark says that i
agree with and you know
how how sure am i that that's true
versus how sure about this other thing
is true and does this really follow for
the stuff that i'm sure that i actually
agree with about which is much harder uh
you know by my essay i'll say it was an
attempt to kind of like
write into the teeth of of that exact
thing that you're talking about with
with that sort of
marxist hostility to uh
to the word because like they
that the title was literally marx was a
liberal
uh or you know i mean i had
philosophical apprentices but you know
like that uh
because because i think that once we get
a lot clearer on what we mean uh then i
think the relationship looks really
different especially because one of the
biggest things i've talked about there
that like if you watch the thing that
matt and i did on the jacob and youtube
last year you know that we talked a lot
about there is just like try to sort out
the different things you could be by
that because i think one of the things
that really hobbles this discussion when
people do use that ism shorthand uh is
that
um
same is true to a certain extent for
socialism but really especially for
liberalism
like that means just wildly different
things and so i think a lot of times
when people say oh i'm a marxist i hate
liberals and liberalism
like there are four or five different
definitions that they're conflated there
right like does that mean like i hate
like political philosophies that are
inspired by like john locke's view of
property rights does that mean
does that mean i hate the idea that
liberal rights you know free speech and
freedom of religion and all that stuff
are unimportant you know uh just does
that mean that uh does that mean that i
hate liberals in the dominant
contemporary sense which is like the
political spectrum sense like the uh
like liberals as opposed to radicals and
those i think are three very different
things we're just gonna have a much more
useful discussion if we separate them
out
yeah for sure um
eric unlike the topic of sort of
you know the usefulness of ideology for
solving i guess more specific problems
or when we're looking for specific
things to solve or specific outcomes we
want in society i know your essay kind
of dealt with the environmental issues
so i wonder like how do you see that
tension between
um like labels and like the tension
between liberal and socialism but then
also like a more dealing with a concrete
problem like climate change or uh yeah
or global warming and stuff
yeah yeah i i
follow the same sort of idea that that
isms can be very unhelpful when you
don't make those kinds of distinctions
within them different different sorts of
let's say like developmental stories
origin stories whatever you want to call
them
so i
yeah like you said i i came at this from
the perspective of a more specific issue
uh and then how that issue gets worked
out in in the sort of political sphere
and how it interacts with different
political world views that obviously
predate this issue which is
environmentalism and climate change and
global warming and those sorts of things
these world views predate this issue by
obviously quite a while and
so i i just wanted to suss out some of
the relevant distinctions you can make
in those political world views and how
they would relate to
environmentalism and and
yeah i noticed the same sorts of things
in in environmentalist literature when
they talk about politics um
for instance for for my
you know if i i'm i'm left leaning right
i i lean towards the left definitely
sort of
the the socialist and social liberal
spectrum there but when i'm looking at
the
the uh environmentalist literature
they normally just talk about liberalism
either
in a sympathetic kind of way um
uh or it's all neo-liberalism right
that's the dominant framework for
addressing environmental issues that
they sort of choose to attack would be
neo-liberalism which is obviously
not what like
matt was just mentioning you know like
like bernie sanders and ocasio-cortez
and elena are more they're not
neo-liberals in that sort of sense of
the word where you
have the free market as the sort of
ultimate guiding sort of light along
which politics has to develop and what
we should cherish and defend is the free
market
but this is the dominant kind of
framework for a lot of the
environmentalist literature when they're
looking at say
neoliberal environmentalism in a global
way
you have the united nations and the the
climate change framework and the cop
conferences and those sorts of things
and this is where this is where this
framework kind of emerges where we have
this free market that we have to defend
somehow and how much do we really want
to give over to government regulation
and i i found it was helpful to
distinguish the sort of hardline
neoliberal approach to it where
all we need to do is preserve the free
market and add sorts of incentivizations
for different things right like create
carbon credit markets and all these
sorts of
economic mechanisms
or do we need more direct interventions
and i sort of correlated these different
ideas with different kinds of political
outlooks so you have you know on the
most extreme left side you might have
things like eco-marxism and eco-fascism
and then like eco this nico that right
the the sorts of leftist approaches um
and then you have
more socially liberal approaches where
they do admit a certain amount of
regulation then you have the sort of the
what i would say the dominant framework
in which these issues get dealt with
does skew neo-liberal in the sense that
the free market needs to be protected
and that mechanisms should be as as
little invasive as possible into the
sort of business as usual kind of
way we're trying to deal with climate
change at this juncture
even though
the issues are very serious and a lot of
people are not down with that
so that's why i was i was coming at it
through the lens of this particular
issue so i also found
making distinctions to be really
important because if you just say all
we're dealing with is neoliberalism
versus socialism then obviously they're
irreconcilable but if you admit
some kinds of
[Music]
like you know if you admit more nuanced
distinctions within liberalism and
within socialism within all these
different approaches that we're seeing
on the global stage today then there are
actually a lot of overlap and a lot of a
lot of opportunities to
you know work together and compromise on
certain things rather than just looking
at one versus the other i think eric
raises a great point here uh which is
the question of to what extent can
liberalism be extricated from
the logic or the ethic of market society
right uh and what's interesting is that
for some on the political left and for
that matter for some defenders of market
society like fa hayek they can't be
extricated right liberalism just is the
ideological defense of market society i
think hayek and some marxist would
completely agree with that uh but my
contention is that
you can't extricate a great deal of
liberalism maybe even everything that's
central to liberalism from the logic or
ethic of market society right
and that doesn't mean that one has to do
this or it's inevitable or teleological
or whatever but it's not conceptually
impossible and the kind of genealogy
that i trace in my book is to say or my
sorry section is to say look
if you look at the kind of epicenter of
liberal and socialist thought what
distinguishes them both from
conservatism uh is this belief that at
least according to nature people are
moral equals uh you can find this
argument made in the second treatise on
government you can find it in the
leviathan
where you start to see the logic of
market society emerging in the classical
liberal tradition is the claim that
precisely because people start off as
moral equals within nature
what makes them differentiated in
society uh in terms of their property
entitlements is how much labor uh
they're willing to
commit to enriching themselves and their
natural capacities
and what's really damaging about this
from a socialist perspective uh is at
least according to the old conservative
or scholastic worldview
if there was inequality in society it
was because it was set by god and it
wasn't necessarily people's fault and
you would see people say things like the
poor are to be pitied or show compassion
not necessarily very nice but not
necessarily
damning either because this is just the
order that god wants what you see in the
classical liberal tradition is this
expectation that precisely because
people start off equal by nature that
justifies them as and condemning them if
they don't rise to the top because it
could have risen to the top they just
didn't cut it per se and i think a lot
of the alienation and animosity that we
feel in contemporary neoliberal society
flows from that
conception that you see in the kind of
possessive individualist strains of
classical liberalism
saying that uh right i think that
there's no need for liberalism to think
this way
and what i think you start to see over
the course of the 19th century and the
20th century as a gradual awareness of
the moral arbitrariness that defaults
all life uh and this sense that starts
to emerge in people like mary wilson
kraft and kant through john strip mills
through rawls and nussbaum uh that
actually
condemning people for being poor is just
as foolish as praising them for being
rich many of the reasons why people rise
and fall
occur for morally arbitrary reasons if
they're not the result of historical
prejudice and discrimination i should
say uh ergo there's no reason for
assuming that the
market order of things uh is somehow
justifiable from a liberal perspective
uh so this is the kind of argument that
i wanted to make uh not to imply that
liberalism isn't compatible with market
society but that it doesn't have to be
and when you understand things this way
i think there's a lot that socialists
can actually learn from the liberal
tradition and vice versa yeah if if
you're if you're a kind of
someone on the left who acknowledges the
urgency of
of the situation under under climate
change and where we're going and
and
you disagree for instance that 2050 is
and and is a good target or that you
know carbon neutrality being like net
neutrality is a is a meaningless kind of
political word that's just designed to
sort of delay action rather than you
know be something meaningful but if
every time you're you're speaking it to
a political audience and you're
identifying liberalism your holy grail
of liberalism is like milton friedman
and the chicago boys and you you don't
talk to people who are potential allies
but still identify as liberals but maybe
not the hard line economic liberalism
that's why sort of socialism social
liberalism or political liberalism
versus the sort of economic
neoliberalism
uh if that's if that's always going to
be the way you frame your argument is
talking against neoliberalism then
you're gonna miss a lot of potential
like overlap and more moderate positions
i think between the two yeah i wonder
about that i mean i think it's certainly
gonna depend
very based on the country uh like
so so this is why
you know i think it's useful to to
separate out like liberalism as a
position on the contemporary political
spectrum
from liberalism as this as this sort of
underlying assumption because
you know because like the question of
how
much people who identify as liberals
are are useful political allies or
potential political allies or whether
they're more allies or enemies you know
i mean i think it's just a very
different question
uh from from the question about about
like broader sort of historical or
philosophical liberalism like i know in
the united states about 25
of the population
you know calls themselves liberal
compared to like two-thirds of the
population says we should tax rich
people more you know so so i'm i'm
pretty i'm pretty skeptical that you
know that that catering too much to the
25
is uh
you know is actually that is actually
that politically uh politically
important i mean the climate change
issue is really hard because
i also don't pretend to know what the
political strategy is that would
actually like secure
you know radical action and climate
change in any kind of like time frame
martha's vineyard sinking underneath the
ocean might be an important catalyst i
just i'll just put that forward
yeah i mean if that happens maybe you
know if that happens soon enough maybe
we're good uh other otherwise i have
absolutely no idea
yeah
i mean that's the other thing right
waiting for some big horrible event to
change everybody's mind about it rather
than addressing the way people think
about the world today and trying to you
know
instill a sort of more uh maybe a less
human-centered kind of focus because
liberalism is very human-centered very
kind of
distinguished non-humans are the things
we the things we
mine and the resources we use and they
enter into our markets whereas like if
you
try to argue from a philosophical
perspective that
non-humans and
ecology and all these things are
extremely important and actually there
are fundamental assumptions we make
when we do politics and when the way our
economic system works it depends on
functioning ecosystem services it
depends on things like that if you can
try to address people's fundamental sort
of worldview and their philosophies
maybe i mean maybe they're vague and not
worked out but you can appeal to them in
various ways and if we try to convince
people that those things are important
then we can try to get a little more
pro-activity
maybe built into our approach to climate
change instead of just waiting for
venice or the vineyards to to sink
underwater and then wake everybody up
and we'll do something because by then
maybe it'll be too late
it might well be i mean didn't ben
shapiro point out that you know if
martha's vineyard's gonna fall under the
ocean or florida's gonna sink then
people will just sell their homes uh for
a profit and go somewhere else right
it's an easy fix so i'm not even
convinced that'll work yeah no that's
that is
that like speaking quickly and sounding
confident could can go a long way when
you uh when you say something like that
i mean i guess i i guess i do probably
think that any chance of of getting
you know serious action on climate
change is probably i'm really not
optimistic about like turning the
majority of the population into deep
ecologists and time in time for that
so i was i kind of wanted to uh switch
topic a little bit and and i wanted to
ask about um sort of maybe
what one of the main critiques of like
philosophical liberalism and like
probably even the critiques of the more
um like left liberal ones like like
rawls like the philosophical is is i
think that and this is a critique that i
think comes from both the right and the
left uh from the socialists and also
like now these are merging you know post
liberals with like patrick dinning and
all them and i think it's this question
of sort of well it's built into the
structure of rawls right in the fact
that that he that he prioritizes the
right over the good right like your
rights over like what like what some
conception of the good life is and i
think often what you get from people on
the right sometimes they'll say well
that doesn't really leave room for you
know maybe some more like transcendent
things but like setting that aside i
think both
uh like people on that that spectrum of
the right and also so more socialists
will say it's like this this this
meaningful community like thick meaning
structures that you get from like
community and that's why i think you get
even more like analytical marxists like
g.a cohen and i know that he describes
in why not socialism he says
you know to foster this kind of
community where not only do we care
about others but we care about caring
about others like we care that we care
and it's like this sort of like thicker
attachment to others and it does seem
like even in the more um like
egalitarian economically egalitarian
forms of liberalism philosophical
liberalism it's it's hard to see
where you can get that and where you can
find and i wonder uh who for whoever
wants to pick pick the pick up on this
like like do you see that as a problem
is it reconcilable because for me at
least i i see that as like as like kind
of attention and like you know i'll just
say that that for me
i've kind of you know resigned myself to
thinking that that's probably not
something that can be reconciled and i'd
just like rather be a liberal like i'd
rather be on the liberal side because to
me i feel like
um those like meaning structures maybe i
don't know for sure this is very like
preliminary thoughts but might depend on
a kind of coercive element of society
some sort of like that that that kind of
instills coerc like i'm
coercive conformity whether it's through
social mechanisms or obviously more
troubling possibility like some sort of
governmental but uh yeah i wonder what
any of you guys might think about about
that yeah i'll just jump in really
quickly because um it's one of the
things that my essay talks about
actually um because i do think that is a
very legitimate criticism you can make
of left liberalism and i often say that
i'm a liberal socialist not a liberal
and a socialist right because i think
that we want to get the best
synthesis uh of individualism and
communitarianism together as possible
that doesn't mean that it's going to be
a kind of utopian aspiration because i
think there'll always be some tensions
between these two yearnings but we might
be able to get a kind of better
synthesis than what we have right now
and the thing that i often appeal to to
try to bring these two together and i
criticize rawls for this amongst others
uh is a kind of democratic or involved
civic life right because i do think that
democracy civic participation uh
localism even of the type that the post
liberals are so fond of uh can be a way
of committing people both to pursuing
their own interests while at the same
time engaging with others deliberating
and trying to understand where other
people are coming from within their
community and i do think there are
models of this being achieved quite
successfully uh whether you think about
the labor movement uh or if you wanted
this more contemporary uh there's a lot
of experiments with local forms of
deliberative democracy in scotland uh
right now where people the community
come together discuss what kind of
policies they want the municipality to
advance uh and then they essentially uh
propose legislation uh through these
kinds of formats it's been very
successful thus far it's still trial uh
so we'll have to see um
and i think that that socialism has a
very robust account of what these
democratic forms of life
could entail and why it is that we can
expand the democratic ideal to things
like the economy to things like the
local level and i think that's a
necessary complement uh to our liberal
intuitions where i think it's important
to be liberal and not go too far with
this uh is recognizing the necessity of
imposing restrictions on the exercise of
things like state power uh irving howe
wrote a really good essay about this uh
liberalism and socialism articles of
conciliation where he said uh one of the
big problems that socialists have always
had going back to marx is this
expectation that if we just give the
state limitless license to do anything
it will
be able to bring about better conditions
for us all uh and i think he's right in
arguing that liberals have been more
sensitive to
the potential tyrannical dimensions uh
of unchecked state power than at least
many socialists uh have been not all i
think you know bakunin for example is a
notable exception to that but but
certainly howe's bigger point is is
right you know that that like this this
is
clearly something you should worry about
uh and this is clearly something you
should worry about post-capitalist
societies right see the 20th century i
think that cohen does nail rolls on some
places where rawls is kind of trying to
have both ways on these issues
and and showing that that's not always
convincing that like uh like like rawls
will say
you know their passage is where he says
stuff like uh well the great thing with
the difference principles that we could
all relate to each other the way that
like
you know like people care about each
other who are like in a family that you
only you know you only want to be better
off than them if that's going to like
you know serve their interests at the
end
and he and and i think cohen's very good
at sort of showing it's like well no
right because like if if you're if you
really cared about somebody like you
care about a member of your family right
you you take
you know you take the more egalitarian
uh you know wages uh to uh you know and
still work just as hard you know because
because you'd be motivated by caring
about them
uh but then the question is if he's
right that there are these
contradictions and roles like how do you
resolve them and and
do you resolve them in a more liberal
way or in a more communitarian way
i think that one interesting thing about
this is that i think that in some ways
um
this sort of more communitarian stuff
and the insistence that like
a really just society is one where
everybody has the right ethos towards
each other we care about each other we
care about caring about each other like
you're quoting from that book which i
obviously like very much overall but
like i actually think this is coed at
his least marxist
like that's that's that's i mean i i
don't know dude that sounds more like
christianity to me you know like like i
i think i think the marxist tradition is
about seeing you know
justice in terms of like structures and
institutions
and uh and being very realistic about
about how people are going to act within
those structures and institutions
uh and and focusing on that rather than
what anybody's ethos is right and i
always feel like there's a little bit of
ambiguity about this and and about this
question of what is market freedom
exactly because i think like like
there's there's a sense in which like i
guess basic freedoms maybe imply a form
of market freedom just in the sense of
like freely being able to associate with
people to be able to trade things to be
able to like write in its and it's like
at what point does
does that sort of association right like
like become market freedom that maybe we
want to put a put like a stop to or like
or at least like limit in some way
but then there's like a sense in which
you know this sort of like eliminate
like a non-market situation right like i
guess a lot of people would would wonder
and you know i still i mean i'm sure
there's there's answers but but i just
haven't at least in the discussion seen
it clearly articulated when i like see
debates about this and it's like you
know what what would it what would that
look like what would the mechanism be
that would prevent
uh it and like people would still
presumably be able to just like buy
stuff from each other like i don't know
like like have a store or you know so i
i wonder if there's some way of
disambiguating that
i would point out that you could raise
all the same questions about all the
ways that we live at markets uh already
right so i mean this is a problem for
like pretty normal forms of left
liberalism too you know like like if you
know like if you're
why is it why aren't minimum wage laws
you know um you know restrictions of
non-market freedom ultimately you know
because they stop people from associated
freely yeah that's that's that's totally
true um
but i but but i think like when you when
you just when you think about like a
non-market socialism
that's like uh you know i i i struggle
to to see what that would look like
right because like obviously putting
certain kinds of limitations you know
minimum wages it's like you know markets
are still you know allowed to proceed
there's just these like limitations uh
but then like a non-market situation
it's like i can't really
it's hard to to imagine what that would
look like exactly without like some form
of obviously what we all i'm sure not
want which is like involve
some uh you know surveillance state uh
making sure that there's no black market
forming right or something like that
where people are doing this like market
activity in the background because it's
tech which i'm sure none of us would
want so
yeah i don't think any of us want the
command economy uh i actually have like
a kind of point that i'd like to make
about this uh and i think we should pass
it off to eric uh because i actually
think that there's some important uh
environmental questions that kind of
flow from this right to what extent can
we put restrictions on the market and
does that entail a restriction on our
freedom because of course this is
exactly the argument you're going to see
neoliberal defenders of market solutions
to environmental problems put forward
right that well yeah maybe we it will
you know
enable us to better protect the
environment uh if you impose strict
state restrictions on what people are
able to do but isn't that a compromise
with individual freedom very common
argument right uh but my kind of claim
to this uh is that look you know uh
there's no doubt that the command
economies uh that operated on the
socialist name over the course of the
20th century were dramatic failures uh
not just dramatic economic failures in
many respects uh but also
totalitarian tyrannies that no one in
their right mind would want to emulate
aside from a couple tankies on the
internet right and we all know what i
think of them right uh i think that a
more legitimate kind of socialism that
has the best features of market society
uh with a more kind of egalitarian
outlook one where you do have different
competitive uh firms but they're
organized democratically by workers who
redistribute the goods that are produced
and sold to their members while at the
same time complemented by an extremely
robust welfare state
that takes a lot of the surplus that's
produced by these firms to give it to
those who are unable to compete in this
kind of market society right and i think
you already see templates for something
like this with the scandinavian or if
you want to call it nordic uh kind of
welfarist models or code determination
in germany it would just be taking it to
the next kind of level bhaskar sukhara
sometimes calls five minutes after
capitalism right and i think this would
also preserve incentives for economic
activity while democratizing power which
is really what i think the crucial
element of the socialist critique of
markets has been from the very beginning
right that it distributes power and
consequently wealth and economic
opportunities in a very in egalitarian
way
what tends to be relevant for the
environmentalist perspective
when you're talking about defending the
free market is uh this sort of optimism
about
competition and innovation right that
that somewhere down the pipeline there's
some great new technology that is going
to come along and save us whatever it is
carbon capture technology or something
like that and that if you put
limitations on
our abilities to you know elon musk
would be like our green messiah or
something right yeah yeah our our eco
jesus is going to come along and save us
and if you put limitations on those
people's abilities to
anybody's ability to associate
economically and pursue their sorts of
in individual interests
then you will hamper the sorts of
innovations that we need to save
ourselves from this problem that we've
created in the first place through
burning fossil fuels
and so that's one of the things that
follows from i think
i i guess that's one of the the
the ways that
free market defenders then can turn to
the environmental issue and say well if
you you know if you hamper innovation
we're going to lose all of these
technologies that will probably go to
save us down the line and i have no
response to that maybe that's true maybe
if maybe if we do start limiting you
know maybe if we do start emphasizing
that we need to get rid of fossil fuels
and move on to green technologies and do
that in a kind of artificial
imposed kind of way rather than just let
the prices naturally fall
maybe maybe then we will lose out on
some innovations that will actually be
crucial but then these are just giant
what if questions and that's why i try
to avoid sort of forecasting or or
addressing any solutions i was just
trying to point out some
where there's differences you know
obviously we don't
you know the the revolutionary kind of
total
change in society approaches
is maybe not the way to go about it you
have to look about what kinds of
reformists and what kinds of local
resistance and direct action
can go along with the sorts of broader
like i was saying before addressing
climate change within an international
framework where you have countries
coming together and discussing how they
fit into these sorts of paris climate
agreements and the
and the rio conferences and all of those
things how they how what can countries
do at that level and then what can
people do more at an individual level of
communicable organization
and i think i think
the the sorts of individualism that you
get with liberalism can be a little bit
more difficult at the grassroots level
cashing out at the grassroots level of
of communal organization and direct
action and
i mean even here in canada the tone i
still see the media taking towards
people who are blockading development
projects and people who are you know
protesting
the ways that companies will you know
suck all the resources out and then and
then cap the well and run off and never
do anything about it never you know they
create all these cleanup problems but
because of the legal framework we work
within they can just leave and not be on
the hook for those costs right
so i just tried to look at what you know
from the free market perspective well
those are external costs right i did my
business i extracted my coil i pumped my
wells everything that comes out of that
the cleanup and all the other [ __ ] that
you have to deal with in the future
that's those are external costs how do
we how do we internalize those costs and
how do we how do we
address those both at the level of
policy making but also at the level of
of of direct action communal
organization blockadia those sorts of
ideas as well
we still have this underlying ethos of
infinite growth and
productivism for production's sake and
trying to bring it again on the more
philosophical level towards this ethic
of care and towards this
you could say deep ecology
or an appreciation for the
interconnectedness of life and
giving non-humans and a voice in
politics as well i would say just
looping back to the question about uh
about markets that
like
it's obviously not my position
uh i mean i'm with matt uh more or less
i mean i i think that um
whether we could ever like figure out
how to do
a completely planned economy that wasn't
you know that didn't end up with the
sort of
economic dysfunction of the soviet union
uh
you know it i'd
regard as an open empirical question i
mean like if like super computers in the
future you know could give us read
plenty then great right but uh
shout out to pils and his cybersyn
documentary yeah no exactly right like
so so if that yeah so
if that happened right like if that sort
of possibility that was represented by
by you know by the
like what the designers of cyprus were
were sort of ultimately envisioning or
like what you know anybody who's ever
read uh you know that novel read plenty
you know about those computer scientists
and the soviet union the chris jeffera
who were like
thinking along these same lines or
whatever like
if that happens great right uh but yeah
i mean i i think you know my
thoughts about what could happen five
minutes after capitalism are
you know largely in line with what matt
said and what boscar thinks all that um
i i think you know but i'd be ha i would
say right i think what if there was
somebody who's more confident about the
prospects for effective planning than
any of us probably are was here in this
discussion i think that a point they
would make
is that markets don't just like spring
out of the ground you know like weeds
right markets are
a result of complex social arrangements
that that enable them to uh to exist
certainly or at the very least markets
on the scale of like what we think of as
a market economy right now are right i
mean
markets exist in a variety of other
kinds of societies but nothing like this
and
you know there are all sorts of ways in
which that relies actually on state
action
most obviously
uh currency right you know like like
good luck having a thriving market you
know without like some sort of currency
everybody accepts
um
no bitcoin couldn't do it longer
discussion but no
uh so um
[Music]
i i think that you know so i think they
say it's not just a matter of well there
will be markets unless we do something
to stop it you know and even if you
think about black markets you know i
think you generally get black markets
on any significant scale at least for
for two reasons one is the reason that
you get like
black markets and drugs or you know or
bad goods or whatever which is that
people want things they can't find in
legal markets or
two
uh the reason that you get black markets
you know if you walk around like you
know manhattan you know there'll be
people trying to sell you like dvds or
you know lose cigarettes or whatever
which are all available at the legal
market but the reason you have that
black market
is that there are lots of like
desperately poor people who like this is
this is the way they've come up with to
to um
to support themselves so i think that i
think the planning advocate would say
well you know we without necessarily
having like the nkvd there to stop you
you know we could still avoid you know
having a black market at a significant
scale
if if we
aren't like
right you know probably some things we
do need to ban because they're
incredibly dangerous you know but like
you know but we we try not to ban too
many things that people want and uh and
and we try not to have an underclass of
people who are desperate enough you know
to try to support themselves this way
and then i think the real question is
whether economic plan is going to get
you those results and again at least
right now i'm skeptical but real quick
on the environmental question
uh i actually do think that like this is
one of the best criticisms that like
non-market socialists could make of
market socialist proposals because
what we ultimately have to say about
that is that our solutions to these
things are kind of the same as the
solutions
of just like regular pro-capitalist
liberals you know that like that they're
ultimately going to be regulatory
solutions rather than solutions that are
about just
totally re-engineering the economic
incentives
that exist in the system in the first
place
uh because you know but i guess the best
thing that you could say on behalf of
that like why this is any better than
like just what regular liberals would
say
about the environment is that even if
the solutions are ultimately gonna be
the same
i like the chances of good policies
on the environment emerging from
political deliberation way better if
that political deliberation doesn't
involve lobbying by exxon mobil
absolutely
but by the way victor uh i had a
question for you uh i'm just gonna make
a comment but i know that your essay
touches on some of uh these themes uh
with your argument for a kind of
reformist approach to democracy
particularly through sororitian
because one of the major
visceral motivations behind writing this
book is just precisely that if you spend
a lot of time uh in leftist or liberal
circles you'll find that a lot of people
there don't like the other side very
much uh even if they haven't spent a lot
of time actually thinking about what the
other side happens to believe uh and
that's not to try to whitewash our
differences and say that everyone is
actually actually believes the same
thing we just haven't really talked
about it enough yet i don't think that's
true uh and i do think that socialists
and liberals have good criticisms of
each other um
we've addressed in some depth here but i
do find that there are a lot of people
for whom
the disdain for liberalism uh flows less
from any kind of deep thinking about
what liberals actually believe uh and
more out of a kind of aesthetic
attraction to the idea of radicalism for
its own sake uh that i also think is
very undialectical right this notion
that we don't want to reform society or
change society or innovate society we
want to break society um there's almost
this kind of cerelian grandeur
associated with the idea of radicalism
and revolution for its own sake and i do
think that that's very unhelpful not to
mention very undialectical because it
presupposes that you can have this kind
of millennium year one type approach to
reconstructing society
and reforming everyone carp launch that
i don't think is either realistic or
particularly helpful in getting people
beyond this kind of uh the people who
are attracted to this aesthetics of
radicalism onside with what we're
proposing uh on the other front i do
think that many liberals just associate
socialism with radicalism for its own
sake because they kind of buy into this
stereotype and they don't recognize that
there's a very long history of
democratic socialist parties social
democratic parties from the spd uh down
to the socialist party of france that
have enacted extraordinarily important
reforms that have benefited millions of
people
and that are
widely popular in fact so widely popular
today that no one thinks of challenging
them
i was speaking to jeremy gilbert the
other day the author of 21st century
socialism and one of the great parts of
his book is he says if you ask people
what the most popular institution in the
united kingdom is
without a doubt immediately they say the
nhs uh which is brought to us by
a socialist party right uh and it's so
popular that even margaret thatcher at
the height of your infamy if you want to
call it that uh gave a speed saying you
know the nhs is safe for us because
that's an achievement that we gave to
the world uh that no one is willing to
take away
so what was the question
well my question i'm kidding i'm kidding
[Laughter]
just making fun of your long your very
grandiose long-winded uh questions no
it's great it's great it's a great the
great set of things it's not it's not a
response by me if it's not grandiose and
long-winded victory you know that
here's here's a shorter way to
ask the question uh i always think of
uh the late michael brooks when he was
making fun of a mutual acquaintance that
i'm not going to name here uh
and and he did he'd do this impression
you know where he'd be like
sorry dad i'm a communist
do you think people being like that is a
big problem and is a big
source
of instinctive hostility to anything
that has the word liberal in it
yeah yeah no that's that's well put very
well put um well the reason i brought
this up also is because your essay is a
lot about how we could perform
representative structures yeah i mean i
mean part of the impetus behind the
essay which i think people have probably
heard me talk about i mean i think i
talked about on this podcast i went on i
went on ben's podcast a while ago just
to talk about that essay as well um
but but i think like the impetus has a
lot to do with like my own dissertation
research which right now like i just i
mean i submitted a chapter not too long
ago about the radical democratic theory
tradition which it's kind of situated as
like a response to what was perceived in
like the theory community in like the
egalitarian or left-wing theory
community as like sort of the failure of
marxism because uh
you know marxism for them was based on
this premise that there is like an
ontologically distinct sort of like
working class that is one thing and then
like in reaction to realizing that
actually society has all these sort of
like pluralistic identities and problems
they're just like well we can't really
think about like socialist strategy in
terms of like a one working class like
unit as like as like a separate thing so
instead they you know they kind of
formulate this this this way of
conducting sort of like democratic
contests to be well to radicalize them
sort of to make them
to try to and it ends up having this
sort of like anti-institutional bent
sort of like talking about how like
liberal democratic institutions
um kind of
like erase these inherent pluralistic
differences that exist in society by
like you know like regulating them and
putting them into these channels so like
true differences can't you know express
themselves some of this is influenced by
sort of post-structuralism and stuff
like that but um i i guess one of the
things that i found uh interesting about
that was that all all that like in this
tradition there they have this
requirement that these contests have to
avoid devolving into antagonism so it's
like they want these contests to be like
agonistic right that's the other name
for it agonistic uh democracy
um where you don't want to destroy your
enemy uh you you wanna you wanna sort of
like see the inherent contingency of
your identity and their identity at the
same time and then you can kind of
battle it out but like not to destroy
people and and i i always just found
that that like it seems to rely on this
uh i find unconvincing assumption that
that um
that we can somehow make make people and
they're not really clear on how to do
this um make them i think in a way more
civically virtuous because because i
think like adopting that attitude of
like seeing your interlocutor as not an
enemy to be destroyed but to you to have
what they call agonistic respect for
them where you you know you respect
their their their right to exist and
their claims but you're gonna battle
them and it's like i feel like that's
actually like a pretty intellectually
robust insight to have to like think
about like it
at the very least it's not something
that i think seems like a a solution for
for politics for mass politics
uh right it requires a so
so i i was kind of finding that
unconvincing but wanting more
like more of this like i kind of agreed
with their insights that maybe like
electoral politics at least doesn't
really leave enough space for these
contests to proceed
um but i found this this this kind of
account of
i think it implies even a sort of
perfectionism about human beings that
like we need to cultivate these virtues
in people that i just don't find all
that convincing so i i think i thought
that like sortition
was like an interesting institutional
alternative that would kind of allow for
more of these
sorts of
true political contests to occur but um
but in a way that doesn't sort of like
rely on
as much of this sort of like just
wanting to be against institutions all
the time and because it's not you know
like it's not
accounting for like the true nature of
people's diverse identities and stuff
like that and so we need to be against
institutions that are trying to like
crush
my identity just you know going back to
the the michael brooks thing you know
like that that intuition that that that
sort of drive towards being like oh
screw you like you know i'm a marxist
like too bad
ideally what you want to do if you want
to win antagonistic politics is is you
need to uh
you know convince the great majority of
people that uh you know to just be
really crude about it that you know that
that uh the the things that you want are
good for them
and and that anybody who is like really
uh a uh intransigent opponent of the
things that you want you know is an
enemy of them and
i mean good luck doing it like if if
your whole identity is
it revolves around this like aesthetic
attachment to like seeing yourself as
the most extreme possible opponent of
everything that exists
because most human beings have an
entirely rational fear
of flying leaps into the unknown
yeah no total and just let me quickly
clarify to that i just want to make it
yeah every time i every time i hear you
speak about this victor
honestly i think of agonistic democracy
as like passive aggressive democracy
like every time you describe it i get
like desperate housewives 2000 era
office or like the woman from midnight
mass if you've just seen it kind of like
no no like they're really great but you
know that kind of vibe anyway yeah no
totally i totally like and i think maybe
sometimes i'll like undersell like the
type of antagonism they really have in
mind that they're trying to avoid which
is like
you know more like i'm sure like what
ben was describing they would be like
yeah like that's what we mean by like in
a way agonistic although there is a bit
more
um required because of the fact that
there wouldn't necessarily be as many
institutions it would be a bit more like
anarchistic a little bit so you'd need
maybe something stronger but really what
they mean by antagonism is like
something that could potentially lead to
like violence i don't know maybe that
was what you had in mind uh well i mean
yeah i mean i'd like to
avoid violence if at all possible uh you
know both both for like the obvious
moral reasons and also because
it goes back to the same point right
that like it or not right and if you
have
if you have the kind of like rioted
barricade fetish you know that a lot of
this this kind of leftists were talking
about have you know you're going to wish
it were otherwise but the fact is the
vast majority of human beings and
you know the vast majority of times and
places
have an entirely rational dislike of the
idea that this could be violence and
like chaos in the streets
and and and that's gonna be a pretty
powerful motivator for them to oppose
things that they think are gonna are
gonna lead to it right so i think i
think the more you can
uh
do things non-violently the the better
off you are and i'm not saying this is
like a
universal gandhian principle for all
times in all places or anything like i i
think it's good that the union you know
fought the civil war but um
but as and you know if if salvadorian
day had been able to do the same thing
you know go back to cyber sign to defend
democracy in chile i would have been all
for it you know that that uh
like you know but
like you really want to avoid it as much
as at all possible for all the reasons
we've just been talking about and
i but the flip side of that is i think
that like especially if you're talking
about you know the uh transition to a
more egalitarian economic system like
the fact is there just is going to be a
certain percentage of the population
that is just going to be
intransigently
opposed to it uh and
you know you're not gonna you know
there's no moral argument that's going
to get jeff bezos
to uh to accept that it would actually
it's actually more important you know
that that that people you know that
like warehouse workers have good lives
that he gets to go to space
um
so like you just have to defeat him
but i think putting those
together well if you just have to defeat
him but you also
need to want to do it as non-violently
as humanly possible you know uh
if nothing else is a pragmatic
imperative even if it even if you didn't
see it as a moral one
then i think that's all the more reason
that you need to um
get as overwhelming a percentage of the
population on your side as as at all
possible right like you can't get
everybody like root that's just not
realistic but like you could you could
you know the bigger it is right the less
prospect there is for for for trying to
uh
to violently you know prevent social
change i'm just going to say the
solution has been staring us in the face
this whole time uh we need to do that
obnoxious youtube thing they did for
their last album and just automatically
download like complete punk discography
onto everyone's itunes and spotify uh so
to give everybody the right fetish
yeah just just throw it on there from
age 10 forward and we'll let nature take
care of itself the teleology of history
will unfurl as it needed to from the
beginning
good i mean i don't know what do you
guys think i feel like that could be a
good point to end on unless unless uh
anyone else had some some final thoughts
i think we're we're a little over an
hour here so i'm happy ending on that
yeah yeah yeah i'm good with that great
yeah i think we've done the work for
paul grave here
yeah we've done it we've done the work
but also don't buy the books it's gonna
be way too expensive
yeah
i will say that as well check it out
don't buy our book order to your library
yeah yeah yeah like stick it in your
cart at least in amazon and think about
it
wait till you're
yeah i'd like to see uh william shatner
reading it while he's out in space you
know just
hanging out up there
all right
well thanks a lot guys and uh yeah
obviously catch us on another pill pod
the three of the three of us here the
three regular amigos and ben you'll you
can find him on his channel youtube
channel i think it's is it called give
them or did it switch to ben burgess now
uh no that well the youtube chat is
called give them an argument yeah oh
right right so so i mean if you just if
you just would i mean
honestly
like nobody actually types in urls if
you just uh
if if you just cert type either bed
burgers or give them an argument into
into uh like the youtube search bar like
you'll find it
yeah for sure and did you want to plug
anything else when you're here uh yeah i
mean i guess uh the school the cohen
class uh it's that michael abbott's
thing uh somebody by the way who
disagrees with us about markets uh the
school for social and cultural change
uh and uh so that's ss cc right school
for social cultural change
sscc.teachable.com
probably by the time this comes out the
first session will have have happened
but it's recorded on zoom and there's
seven more after that so you know you're
certainly welcome to enroll a little
late
awesome and how has their enrollment
been for that i'm curious do you did you
have you looked or yeah i think it's
like 55 people
awesome so yeah that's great
awesome alright well thanks everybody
yeah thank you
recording stuff
[Music]
you